uh
[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know my
name is c.a murray and i'm in the
company of pastor daniel miranda pastor
good to have you here thank you good to
be here professor murray we love
studying the word of god together and so
this program is is one that we are
particularly fond of i'd like to know
because it gives us two great
opportunities one gives us an
opportunity to go back into the word
but uh as much as that or perhaps even
more than that it gives us an
opportunity to hear what's on your mind
what you're thinking about and the
questions that you may have
as they pertain to the bible as to
christian life as to
the things that we try to do in this
world here and now as we prepare
for the world that is to come at the
second coming of jesus christ so it's a
fun program for us and we love having
your questions
we make
this promise to you as always that we
will try to answer the questions from
the word of god
it is important to us
that we
answer questions from the word of god
our opinions don't really count uh they
don't really matter it's the word of god
that matters it's the truth of the word
of god that matters and as long as we
are
giving the word we might as well give it
from the word of god and we might as
well give you the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so that is
what we pledge and promise to do you
send in the questions if an answer can
be found from the word of god we will
find that answer we will mind that
answer and we will bring it to you you
will note that pastor boris not here
today he is away and uh so we are
manning the fort as it were in his
absence and happy to do so should you
like to get in on the funds should you
like to be part of this particular
program you can do so by sending your
questions to
tv
at some tv.org that's tv
at some tv dot o r g and we will get to
your questions now
sometimes questions come that we sort of
bring to the front of the pile we we
don't necessarily promise to make uh
every answer or give every answer in
order that it arrives we try to and we
tend to but sometimes there are
questions that uh are of a little more
immediacy or perhaps deal with something
that's happening in the world right at
that time so we may bump those up to the
front of the pile uh and and do that but
for the most part we will try to take
them in the order that they arrive but
not always so we give you that one
caveat that one caution so that you will
be aware of that again our object is not
speed it's it's it's an attempt to try
to be thorough so we may take one
question per show we may take two we may
take three all depends on the depth of
the question and the kind of answer that
um you are seeking so that is our
promise brother pastor if you would uh
ask the lord to bless our program today
we'll launch out
in prayer
okay let's pray
dear heavenly father
as we open up your word
we pray that you may lead us and guide
us in this study
we want to find answers only from your
word
and you know that there is out there
sincere children of you
who
are waiting for these answers
so i pray to you lord that
as we open
your word you may guide us and help us
come to all truth in the name of jesus
amen amen amen all right our first
question comes to us we've gotten
several questions from him i think we
will uh exhaust his little pile today
michael
bruce j and hopefully we're not
slaughtering that name too much
we've been looking at this name and
b-r-u-t-s-c-h-e
uh
so bruce j uh hopefully we're not we're
not doing you a disservice dan you want
to read the question and then let's
let's take a look at the answer yes
so
um our brother is quoting prophets and
kings
page
and he says how did nebuchadnezzar
kingdom sustain to the kingdom of heaven
when it was not yet established in his
time
at first i wasn't understanding the
question very well but i think same with
me now it's
501.3 so it's 501 paragraph three
um
that um i think you might have said 503
but it's 501.
this one particular is five over three
you have five or three yes and then
there is one later from him that is five
oh one you're correct you're correct
okay so
i went to the quote and let me read it
for you here
um what it says and and after i read the
quote then i understood what he was
trying to
ask
this is the chapter
that is entitled the fiery furnace
in prophets and kings
chapter 41 page 503
it says the dream of the great image
opening before nebuchadnezzar events
reaching to the close of time
had been given that he might understand
the part that he was to act in the
world's history
and the relation that his kingdom should
sustain to the kingdom of heaven so this
is the question that he has uh the
question is what does it mean that
nebuchadnezzar's kingdom sustained to
the kingdom of heaven
when it was not yet established in his
time so i think this is a problem of
semantics uh what does the word sustain
mean in this in this question this
context yeah yeah yeah so pastor murray
would you
help us answer that
well there are two ways to to apply the
word sustain
uh and i i think the problem is again
the misapplication of the word sustain
if something is sustained until a
certain time
that means that it is kept
until that certain time yes
the other way to look at sustain
is
to
what kind of relationship
do i sustain with pastor miranda what
kind of relationship do i maintain
with pastor miranda so there are two
slightly different ways to look at the
word sustain
yes
what what ellen white is saying here is
the that
it's questioning what kind of
relationship is sustained or exists or
will exist
between
kingdom a
and event b
so it is not saying
that
babylon will be sustained until the
second coming exactly it's asking the
question what kind of relationship will
exist
in light of the second coming yep and i
think that's where the problem is that's
what the problem is exactly so basically
what i understand that ellen y is trying
to say here is that the kingdom of
babylon
was only
um
in relationship to the kingdom of god as
as god presented to nebuchadnezzar in
daniel chapter two
what this is saying here is just simply
that god is the one that sets up kings
and he takes down kings and that
all these kingdoms will basically point
to the final establishment of god's
kingdom and in that train of of of
kingdoms that we have uh the the kingdom
of babylon uh has a relationship with
the final establishment of the kingdom
of god yeah in that sense yes precisely
she's she's pointing out that that
nebuchadnezzar is going to be given an
understanding of where he fits in
exactly fits in
to the the the in the succession of
kingdoms and the succession of of time
moving towards
moving through earth's history to the
coming of the lord where does babylon
fit into that that process where uh does
it where can it be plugged in what is
his particular role
in in that that continuation of our
continuum of kingdoms so um
nebuchadnezzar needs to understand that
he's not going to be here forever he's
got a particular time a particular role
a particular uh part to play but he is
not the whole picture he's just part of
the picture exactly which in the context
of daniel 3
that that was that he missed him he in
daniel 2 he understood that after his
kingdom there become another kingdom yes
but in chapter 3 he says no i want to
make an image all of gold yes yeah and
my kingdom will not fall
and then um uh elenois is quoting in
that context and she says well
uh actually she quotes here daniel 2 44
and 45 in the same quote that our
brother is referring to
where it says that uh
the god is going to set up a kingdom
with that we shall never be destroyed uh
trying to remind us that it was not
babylon that will
be
the the everlasting kingdom but the
kingdom of god
and and and of course the opposite
phrase is that god is going to set this
kingdom up this is not going to be
something that man does not going to be
man's engineering or ingenuity you know
when you look at this this story and and
michael is obviously a student of the
word um and and does study one of the
things that
becomes very obvious uh daniel is the
fact that god took unusually
long measures
with nebuchadnezzar he he was more
patient
uh with nebuchadnezzar than he was with
many of israel's kings
the the the chain was much shorter on
them but he he labored with
nebuchadnezzar and of course we find out
that nebuchadnezzar is is is going to be
saved nebuchadnezzar is in uh we praise
the lord for that but god worked hard
with him uh uh
at least three visionary experiences and
and and many miracles you know when when
he was out eating grass for seven years
god sustained that kingdom for him
um
so uh
his patience was rewarded there i say
with the nebuchadnezzar uh
hard-headed guy sometimes and and very
rash yes but uh
uh god labored with him and uh added one
more to to the kingdom hope she can say
praise the lord and say amen amen
alrighty um
so i think we we
we've dealt with that uh
again the burden was the word sustain
and how it is plugged in how it is used
um
let's look at the second question um
daniel would you read that one for us
yes it comes it's coming from the same
brother michael berce
and
he is asking
a question in regards to daniel 6 26
and
let's read it first
so that we can understand his question
daniel chapter 6 verse 26 says
i make a decree this is darya speaking
that in every dominion of my kingdom men
must remember
excuse me men must tremble and fear
before the god of daniel
for he is the living god
and steadfast forever his kingdom is the
one which shall not be destroyed and his
dominion shall endure to the end
so after quoting this he asks is king
darius making a decree that all men
tremble and fear god his dominion
his kingdom or is he saying that god's
kingdom and dominion
will last unto the end without being
destroyed
so that is the first question
i believe he is speaking of both
yes
precisely
he is speaking about the
the key here again is the
emoji the 50 cent word the antecedent
of the word his who is the his that's
that is referring to yes well he's not
talking about his own kingdom he's
talking about the kingdom of god so he
establishes that
uh early on i make a decree
that in every dominion of my kingdom
men must tremble in fear before the god
of daniel so the object is the god of
daniel
for he the god of daniel exactly is
is the living god and steadfast
forever
his the god of daniel
kingdom is the one which shall not be
destroyed
and his the god of daniel dominion shall
endure to the end
so it's all based on
uh the god of daniel and all of the
statements about eternity about power
about standing forever are focused on
the god of daniel not uh his own kingdom
yeah this doesn't have anything to do
with me or persia
and then he he relates this to daniel 2
44 and he says in either case it seems
to me that these two kingdoms of daniel
6 26 the two kingdoms he is referring to
his middle persia and god's kingdom are
contemporaneous
and that the kingdom that won't be
destroyed is the same kingdom that was
made known to king nebuchadnezzar in
daniel 2 44. yes precisely
what as you just explained it
uh he's making references to god's
kingdom the god of daniel yes and
that god's kingdom is the one being
referred to here yes he gets to the
right point so point plays rather but
though his root is a little circuitous
yes uh but the the only kingdom that is
going to stand forever
is the one that is established by god
him himself
amen now um i think this is the last one
um
from from michael my question comes from
reading prophets and kings this is 501
541 paragraph three
um
how did the kingdom of daniel
shatter and break babylon if it is not
as some supposed to be set up until the
second coming of christ you have that um
the 244 paragraph three
501 paragraph three i'm sorry
501 paragraph three yes
um i have it here in the history of
nations the student of god's word may
behold the literal fulfillment of divine
prophecy
babylon
shattered and broken at last
passed away because in prosperity his
rulers had regarded themselves as
independent of god and had ascribed the
glory of their kingdom to human
achievement
the middle persian realm was visited by
the wrath of heaven because in its
because in it god's law
had been trampled under food
the fear of the lord had found no place
in the hearts of the vast majority of
the people wickedness blasphemy and
corruption prevailed the kingdoms that
followed were even worse more base and
corrupt
and this sank lower and still lower in
the scale of moral wars so i think his
his confusion is that
how is it that the kingdom was
shattered
the kingdom of babylon
when
we see in the in the prophecy that it is
with the rock
that shatters all the kingdoms that
happens at the second coming
so how did the kingdom of daniel 2 44
shatter and break babylon
if it is not as some supposed to be set
up until the second coming of christ
that's his question
well historically
historically babylon was shattered by
middle
persia now some people are confused when
they see
the rock
smiting the image
still the head still standing
the whole image still standing
are these kingdoms going to be standing
when jesus comes the second time
precisely not no
the the rock smites the feet of the
image that is the kingdom that will be
standing
but why is the whole image standing
because although those kingdoms fell the
principles from those kingdoms were
passed to the to the following kingdom
and to the following kingdom for example
we we have uh we have principles of
babylon still today living
in spiritual babylon sun worship for
example
the worship of idols and
the
the desire for power
all these things these characteristics
that we see in literal babylon
we also see them in spiritual baptism
yes today these these kingdoms succeeded
each other through conquest and
conquering
the mindset
that set up one
[Music]
fell through as you well said to the
other
um when this image comes and i think
where he's having a bit of a problem is
is the shattering the shattering is the
shattering
these kingdom kingdoms conquered each
other but the mindset was there so they
are all standing
in the days of these kings these last
set of kings down in the toes of the
image then god's kingdom will be set up
yes it it
it hits the image on the feet and of
course the entire image comes down so
that means that the systems that
undergirded all of these kings that
undergirded all of these kingdoms is
going to be destroyed along with the
with the the the the the kingdoms
themselves so
what what
is happening is
that a whole new way of life a whole new
way of dealing with the world a whole
new regime is going to come in and
replace that which
was there here to four um so all of that
that we know now all of that that we see
now all of that that we you know we as
we're doing this program we're right in
the middle of a
war terrible war
so the mindset daniel as you well know
has not changed no man is still
conquering into conquer and
this kind of thing is going to go wars
and rumors of wars
right up until the second coming of the
lord and that's what that image is
trying to show us that that nothing has
changed as far as the mindset of man is
concerned
and when god brings in his new kingdom
this whole dispensation is going to be
away with that from then on to something
new that will not ever change that will
not ever fall that will not ever falter
uh and all of it will be will be
destroyed amen
satan has been trying to establish his
kingdom and he's been setting up his
kingdom kingdom throughout all these
kingdoms
every
each kingdom has made a contribution
to satan's final object yes
um and we also say it in revelation 13
uh with the first beast of of
that that john sees yes um babylon mira
persia and greece had already fallen but
then this beast has the mouth of a lion
yes the the feet of bear composite it's
a composite beast exactly so we see that
these rom roman bees
papal beast as we understand the papacy
has inherited the characteristics of
these other kingdoms and all
of them all exactly so in that way they
stand unto the end but not politically
well said well said and of course
i would would
remand michael to look at romans
romans revelation 13 the the sea beast
verses 1 through 11 and in verse 11 we
pick up the united states and prophecy
with the land beast
it gives you this understanding that
the kingdoms will not be there in
actuality but they will be there
spiritually yes uh figuratively uh the
mindset will will be there until the
coming of the lord when the lord sets up
a new kingdom
daniel uh
is a good book to study
and uh it's one that you need to take
and choose sort of slowly and work your
way through because it does make sense
it it's very logical it is uh but you've
got to take your time with it and it's
like eating an elephant you know one
bite at a time
don't want to try to eat it all at the
same time yeah but michael is a good
student of the word and thank you so
very much michael for your questions we
really appreciate them and uh
you keep sending them we'll try to keep
answering them um have we dealt with
this all pretty much
yes we have i think we have yes we have
we have
um is israel is the next one yes it is
it is clear
that the influence and power of both the
united states and the papacy are
escalating with rapidity
what other factors could possibly help
set the stage for a worldwide law to
execute those who refuse to violate
conscience it's interesting that we we
ended with we segway with romans chap
revelation chapter 13 right versus
uh
well the entire chapter because it deals
with both entities yes it deals with the
united states in prophecy and it deals
with the the
the papacy but um
uh
what other factors he's asking could
possibly set the stage for a worldwide
law to execute those uh to
who refuse to violate conscience
right
you know revelation 13 as you mentioned
is a really good chapter for this
and
and i would like to parallel revelation
13 with matthew 24.
well done
because in matthew 24
that the specific the specific event
that our brother israel is referring to
is the sunday law where do we see the
sunday law in matthew 24 we see the
sunday law here
in verse
which speaks of the abomination of
desolation therefore when you see the
abomination of desolation spoken of by
daniel the prophet standing in the holy
place whoever reads let him understand
so
we understand in matthew 24 that the
events that jesus describes are
are in chronological order because we
have that word then and then and then
over and over again yes
so
in order for us to see
what is going to take place before
the sunday law then we need to read the
verses that are before
for example verses 6
through 9 and this is what we are seeing
right now
you will hear of wars and rumors of wars
see that you are not troubled for all
these things must come to pass but the
end is not yet
for our nation shall rise against nation
kingdom against kingdom we are seeing
that right now
and there will be famines and
pestilences and earthquakes in various
places and all these are the beginning
of sorrows then they shall deliver you
up to tribulation and kill you and you
will be hated by all nations for my
name's
sake
so
you know ellen white makes reference to
this in the book at the great
controversy i'm not going to read the
entire quote because of time we are
running out of time but
um
our brother israel can take note of
these pages
great controversy page 5
89 and 590
where ellen white describes the things
that will lead up
lead up to a sunday law
and she says for example there that
satan will work in the elements of
nature
uh it says that he
he's going to send famine pestilences
and he's going to spread a deadly taint
in the air and popular cities will be
will will be brought to ruin
and at the end
this is with this purpose
that he will charge all their troubles
upon those whose obedience to god's
commandment is a perpetual reproof and
that the men
of authority in the world are going to
push for a sunday law
because it is going to be claimed that
these things are falling on the world
because of those who are not worshiping
on on on sunday because we're not
keeping sunday
so the things that we are seeing right
now are setting up the stage
for
that push for a national sunday law
because it will be said that these
things are falling because we are not
obeying god and worshiping his holy day
well said
um
to add a little more light to what
you're saying and and your answer is
fabulous daniel um
israel
the answer to your question really lies
there in matthew chapter 24
verses 6 through 8.
nation rising against nation
famines pestilences earthquakes
these are some of the things that are
going to push men
governments
to look for answers
and we tend to try to look for our
answers in in
in a person or an entity that says i can
fix that and we've seen that
a pandemic comes through
and we will step on certain liberties
for the sake of the whole
so the
we can see in our world today
how the mindset can exist because there
are those say well we'd never be forced
to to do this or to do that well in the
wake of a pammon a famine an earthquake
a pestilence uh people will do strange
things and they will they will freely
give up some liberties yes uh
to have safety
so
uh
we're kind of going through this even
now
and of course ellen white's statements
uh i have i have great controversy 589
also oh um
um but but we can see it right there in
in and what is so wonderful about
matthew chapter 24 as you said it is
logical and it is sequential so we can
follow this then this then this then
this then this so we're dealing with
with um
a chronology that is walking us through
to the end of time well
we would never think that a country in
this modern age would just go in and
just invade another sovereign country
but it's happening uh and it's going to
happen again and it's going to keep on
happening
again our time is fascinating to
eternity we'll see you again next time
god bless you we'll see you again soon
bye-bye
[Music]
you